estoy segura de que mi supervivencia es
un milagro porque rezo mucho la familia
de rita tuvo que buscar durante 14 horas
antes de encontrarla en un hospital de
beirut su cráneo y su cara sufrieron
daños graves y ella quedó inconsciente
con la explosión este cirujano plástico
salvó su vida
cuando llegue a los finales del diu con
las cosas comenzaron a mejorar y recibió
un tratamiento rápido para mis ojos mi
mano y otras partes de mi cuerpo
a partir de gran parte de esta parte del
cráneo que fue removida será reemplazada
por una parte artificial gracias a una
impresora 3d en el timón digital
promoción que fuera del área
reemplazaremos sin problema nuestra
plaza y se volverá a la normalidad sí
totalmente será normal
eso es impactante en tu pelo volverá a
ser como eran los de integro rita se
someterá la próxima cirugía en 10 días
para reconstruir su cara tal como era
antes de la explosión
así tenemos muchas heridas faciales
porque la gente estaba en sus hogares y
algunos estaban cerca de puertas o
ventanas entonces fueron arrojados por
la explosión o algún elemento pesado
cayó sobre ellos
de tumbes
trabajo buenos días como estas que están
bien
en el bayern y la explosión me lanzó
contra la pared esta parte de mi rostro
golpeó el muro y comenzó a sangrar
cerca de 100 personas heridas de
gravedad están siendo tratadas en el
hospital hotel
algunas de ellas necesitarán por lo
menos dos años para que sus rostros
vuelvan a la forma habitual